le tireur et moi nous sommes regardés dans
les yeux
j'ai vu le moment où j'étais la cible
de son arme
j'ai été abattu neuf fois par le gouvernement
j'aurai des handicaps permanents et des
douleurs à la suite de ces blessures
mais je suis un turc fort et
têtu  homme qui a été
élevé au bâton seul
le traumatisme vivra avec moi pour toujours
les images l'odeur et le son de la
mosquée ce jour-là me chassent
je ne prévois pas un avenir où je
serai sans douleur
cependant je suis déterminé
déterminé à trouver un positif  voie à
suivre pour surmonter
la douleur faire face à cette distance de la
famille et vivre avec mes handicaps
à l'avenir
je penserai et serai fier de tout ce que
j'ai surmonté alors
que je marche librement au soleil
merci